the race between infection and injection
is on but immunizing the global
population against cobin 19
presents an unprecedented challenge
no one's ever tried to vaccinate an
entire planet
as fast as they're trying to do it now
the rich world has most of the global
vaccine supply
prompting many countries to turn to
chinese and russian jabs
when it's not yet completely clear how
safe or effective they are
it might turn out that these are really
great vaccines but unless you see the
underlying data you can't be absolutely
sure
will gambling on these jabs pay off or
could it have negative consequences for
the great vaccination
drive
new mutations of covert 19 are placing
health systems under increasing strain
and the stakes are higher than ever in
the global vaccination race
it's amazing we've even got these
vaccines at all this has happened
and in under a year it's it's a miracle
i think the challenge for the world now
is how to supply and distribute these
vaccines
just a handful of countries have managed
to give a first dose to over five
percent of their population
and some vaccines are easier to
distribute than others
of the three jabs to have been approved
for use by stringent regulators
two made by pfizer bioentec and moderna
requires storage at low temperatures
making them more suitable for use in the
rich world
israel is leading the rollout of the
pfizer jab
just over 30 of the population have
received at least
one dose making them the most immunized
nation in the world
israel was helped by a deal with pfizer
which gave it access to jabs in exchange
for data about how the vaccine was
working
and the country's size and population
density also helped israel is a small
country
and distributing the fisa vaccine is
easier when you can move it around
without it heating up and spoiling
the third vaccine to receive
authorization from stringent regulatory
bodies offers hope
of wider and faster distribution
developed by astrazeneca and oxford
university
it can be kept in a normal fridge the
astrazeneca vaccine is the vaccine i
think that most of the world will
use it's cheap it will be plentiful
and will be made in lots of places
around the world
but rolling out this vaccine poses two
big challenges
first many poorer countries will
struggle to get it into arms
quickly and safely it's much more than
just flying them to the airport
even though the astra vaccine is
suitable because it can go in a fridge
even india is going to have a real toll
chain problem and the second problem is
that the vast majority of these jabs
have
already been snapped up by the rich
world
three-fifths of the two billion
confirmed orders of astrazeneca doses
will go to high-income countries
along with all of the moderna vaccine
and almost three-quarters of the pfizer
vaccine
even taking into account the high death
rates in the rich world
some nations pre-ordered significantly
more than they will need
america ordered enough to vaccinate the
population twice
over the uk ordered enough to vaccinate
the population
three times and canada where deaths have
been relatively low
ordered enough to vaccinate the
population five times
the director general of the world health
organization has dubbed this hoarding
a me first approach which could increase
suffering
and prolong the pandemic
rich countries ordered more vaccine than
they need they
at some point are going to have to
donate some of it the question is
when are they going to donate that is a
political question
and will depend on the mood of the
countries
involved the good news is that there
is a scheme to make sure lower and
middle-income countries have access to
jabs
it's called kovacs and works like a
global vaccine buying club
that allows rich countries to subsidize
vaccines for poorer countries
and pool demand to get better prices
following his inauguration president
biden was quick to announce america
would join the group of 190
participating economies
the big hope in kovacs is that about
three percent
of each country's population will have
got adequate supplies of vaccine by
the summer that's roughly the number of
healthcare workers
in most countries that's quite a lot but
not enough by any means to vaccinate
much of the world's population
that leaves a large global shortfall in
safe and effective vaccines and in an
attempt to make up for this
many countries are turning to china and
russia
both nations have made vaccines which
they say work
and are safe the problem is it's hard to
know if that's true
they're approved before having gone
through phase three trials
it might turn out that these are really
great vaccines which would be really
good for the world but unless you see
the underlying data you can't be
absolutely sure
governments desperate to immunise their
populations have been making deals
directly with the jab developers to host
clinical trials in exchange for
[Music]
vaccinations chinese vaccines are being
used
or trialled in several countries around
the world including high
income nations like the united arab
emirates
and bahrain which are just behind israel
in terms of the doses of vaccine
delivered per head that's good news for
china
but it's raised concerns the country may
be exploiting the vaccine rollout
for political purposes the pandemic is
such a kind of global
event that inevitably soft power becomes
a factor to it
if you look at the way china has been
doing deals with countries to give its
vaccine to countries in the middle east
it's part of
a move to try and build relationships
with those countries
the lack of transparency around some of
these trials is worrying
the full sinofarm trial data from the
uae were never published
and tests of a different chinese vaccine
in brazil
have also raised questions
a jab made by chinese companies synovac
was initially found to have
78 efficacy but this was later
downgraded to 50 percent
just clearing the threshold for
emergency approval from regulators
none of these countries are free to
disclose their data in the way they
would like because they're
bound by contractual arrangements with
the chinese so they can't tell us what
we want to know
this lack of transparency has important
knock-on effects
on trust and trust in vaccines is
crucial for making them effective
trust is what determines how many people
are willing to take the vaccine
maximum trust depends i think on maximum
transparency
[Music]
the vaccine rollout that has perhaps
raised most concerns around trust has
come from russia
the vaccine named sputnik v was
authorized in russia last summer
after being tested on just 76 people
and has since been cleared for emergency
use in 14 countries worldwide
it's no accident that the russian
vaccine is called sputnik v
a reference to one of the great soft
power triumphs of the soviet union in
getting
the first man-made object into space it
was the first
vaccine to be announced and frankly it
was rushed out
in some ways it was designed to burnish
russia's reputation but the fact that it
went to those lengths and cut those
corners has done russia's reputation no
favors
getting the vaccine rollout right
matters
modeling suggests if jabs are
distributed according
to global need rather than being
concentrated in rich countries alone
it could save one and a half times more
lives
but doing this will require levels of
global cooperation that have been
lacking
in recent years if the world gets it
right
it could pave the way for greater
collaboration on issues like climate
change
get it wrong and it could deepen the
cracks in an already fragmented
global system if it's seen that the
pandemic has been dealt with
well and fairly and that the mechanisms
for governing the world
have functioned then that's an enormous
vote of confidence
but if the pandemic is seen as selfish
and fractious it makes all those other
dishes much harder to deal with
i'm edward carr the economist deputy
editor i hope you've enjoyed this film
if you want to read more of our kovid
coverage please click on the link
opposite and keep an eye out for the jab
our new covet podcast and don't forget
to subscribe